You are listening to
radio lab radio from W.
N y. S. C e.
Okay.
I'm Jad Abumrad. I'm
Robert Krulwich, Radiolab.
And today we have a little experiment
in democracy, diversity and division.
Yeah. Comes to us from our reporter,
producer Simon Adler. Okay. All right.
Sign. Okay. What, what
do you have to tell me?
So couple months back,
I took the train down to
southern Brooklyn, 95th Street,
bound to a little neighborhood called
Bay Ridge that's known for its portrayal
in the movie. Saturday night fever.
[inaudible]
w w you weren't heading there for
disco? Uh, no. Uh, not exactly.
The auditorium appears to be a filling up.
I was actually down there to go to this
Catholic High School Auditorium. Huh?
How you doing? Hey Sir, to the
Classic High School Auditorium,
sloping down with the stage in front
and like an American flag on one side of
the stage in a New York state flag
on the other, maybe a thousand seats.
And I would say half of them
are filled. Like surprisingly,
there's a big turnout for this thing.
Look familiar. Have you seen me before?
Well, mid this question
handsome. Oh. And uh,
it would not be unfair to say that
the crowd has an average age of 62.
The reason I was there. So, uh,
what brings you here tonight? Uh,
Tom seated debate was to watch the local
candidates for the New York City city
council. Duke it out. Who's most likely
to do something for you, do you think?
I have no idea. I've
been hurt on both sides.
And can I ask you a question or two? As
I was talking to people beforehand, uh,
weaving in and out of the rows of chairs,
the issues that people
were concerned about, uh,
were really what you would expect
will be in this
neighborhood for five years.
I've been fighting for a light at this
level of politics. In the meantime,
I get aggravated. We have to run for our
lives when we cross the streets. Yeah,
it's horrible. You know, small stuff.
Taking away the 5 cent
bottle tax with you,
drink a lot of mountain dew or something.
So the 5 cents are going to have my
water bottles. It jumps up the price.
When I buy those, I'm
24 packs of water right
places. We're about to be
eventually the MC for the evening.
This woman in her seventies
dressed from head to toe in pink,
walks out onto the stage.
Jace is America in action.
We Paddock Hooray selection here.
She invites the candidates up,
five Democrats, four Republicans.
They sit down at their respective
tables and okay, we're ready.
It gets underway. You know,
and I'm all get set, go.
And at first
I have a city council woman,
I will help them make sure that those
that have limited in common on fixed
income,
it's pretty dry.
You have enough resources and the
help to take care of that path.
[inaudible] yeah,
so you don't have to put them down
and they don't have to put them out.
But then about an hour, hour and a half
into it, there's this moment where,
what are your solutions for the
overcrowding in schools in this district?
Bug Panel. One of the
Republican candidates, this guy,
Bob Kapono goes off on this riff.
It's a matter of budgetary priorities.
It takes some money to build schools.
So perhaps if we put an end to some of
the cities, sanctuary city policies,
like spending $27 million to defend
those here illegally will commit felonies
for deportation perhaps. And you'd have
more money to build more public schools.
[inaudible]
and then just as it seems like people
were settling down against the next
question. [inaudible]
Devil's breath, right
man on the far right side
of the auditorium stands
up and then goes on to say
the Arab people and the
freaking Asians out of here.
[inaudible]
why are you selling your houses?
You're letting everybody take over.
Yeah.
Everybody sort of sat up
in their seats and uh,
nobody was quite sure if this
thing was gonna escalate.
And shortly after he said this,
one of the candidates up on stage,
this tall guy like six foot three,
salt and pepper beard stood up from behind
the table and actually walked out in
front of it. I want to say something,
at least forgive me. And uh, and said,
that is an elephant in the room and
it's called racism and discrimination.
And this give you that
the right to be here.
You don't have enough [inaudible] to
build the message for Trump and to the
world that the people of the 43rd
district are not afraid to send the first
American city council to represent
[inaudible].
So the reason I was at this debate
is um, like it feels right now,
like America is just at its own throat.
It's certainly as divided as I've ever
seen it and I just keep wondering like in
this moment, can one person
stand for all of us anymore?
And here you've got this guy, the
guy you just heard other Ellia team,
a Palestinian American trying to win an
election in one of the most conservative
and most divided neighborhoods in New
York and he's running on behalf of a group
of people who currently are at
the flashpoint of those divisions,
Arab American Muslims. And just to
make things a little more common.
Okay. The other Elliot team
is a Christian. That grace
of our Lord is the Christ,
the love of God and the communion of
the Holy Spirit. Christian minister.
[inaudible]
yeah, we've been the one in the office.
Yeah, it was [inaudible] check, check,
check.
I sat down with him in his office
for the first time this past march.
I am an Arab American Palestinian
Christian Lutheran Pastor in southwest
Brooklyn running for office.
That doesn't say that for me.
Can you say that once more
in Arab American Palestinian
Lutheran Pastor in south
was to Brooklyn who is running for city
council because I want to bring a new
bold, fresh, inclusive,
powerful voice to present our district
and city council is that you've got a
nice cadence there. You though you
said that you know, being a preacher,
you know it helps a little bit
to what's this guy's backstory?
How did he end up being in Brooklyn and
running for the seat for Cities Council
world?
So he was born and raised in Bethlehem
on the West Bank in a Palestinian,
a Christian home into a family
that was poor to a middle class.
His father was a carpenter and made
most of his money, was the carving.
You know those little like nativity scenes
with the wooden camel and the wooden
Christ. He carved those for a living.
My mother was housewife and she
helped my father in the factory.
They worked extremely hard to
provide for us a good life. So it's,
it was amazing, wonderful symbol
life. It wasn't a complicated.
So I went to school, grew up in
the church and after high school,
Ellia team went into the seminary
of the Bisley Himba College.
And then when he was in his
second year, this was 1989,
I was arrested by the
Israeli soldiers. Um,
I was picked up from
my bed, from home, uh,
three in the morning and
the took me to prison. Uh,
for what reason? I don't know.
I never been given a
reason why I was arrested.
I never been convicted of anything.
I was picked up from my bed, uh,
three in the morning from my
father's house and taken to prison.
I was in a solitary
confinement in a small cell.
He says that the Israeli
soldiers basically tortured him,
hitting me and putting me outside against
the wall with a bag of my head under
the rain and the cold. And they kept
asking me, you tell us what you did wrong.
Tell us what you did wrong. I said,
I have nothing to tell you. Uh,
and a few months later, he was
released with no explanation.
This was a bizarre experience. When he
got home. After I get back from, uh,
Kmart from prison, there was a lot of
people came to our house. They will say,
oh, look, see what they did to you. Now
you have to do this to them. You know,
they'd come to recruit you a to belong
to a political party. In this case,
it was the Palestinian
Liberation Organization,
which at the time was explicitly an
armed resistance movement that often
targeted Israeli citizens. And
the, they will say, oh, look,
see what they did to you and now you
have to do this to them. And I said,
absolutely not. Uh, this is not the
way I want to live the rest of my life.
You know,
I always wanted to be engaged in
a place where I can bring hope.
I can, uh, help people. And, uh,
the only way I can do that was through,
uh, being, uh, become a minister.
So he doubled down in his
studies, finished seminary
with working in Palestine.
And then in the early nineties, uh,
he was actually sent to start a new
Lutheran Church in Bay Ridge, Brooklyn.
So, uh, I came to Brooklyn 1995.
I remember on the first day I was
shocked because Viking Down Fifth Avenue,
if you take the whole neighborhood
in, and we are in Bay Ridge,
which I actually did not too long ago on
eight bike. Uh, what you notice is, uh,
on the right we have Leif
Erickson park a nod to the, uh,
neighborhoods Scandinavian past this
sort of crazy mix of different kinds of
people. The Bay Ridge Bakery,
beautiful neon sign looks like it
hasn't changed much since the 1960s.
Johnny pumps a firemen
bar, firefighter bar.
Did I hit record?
I did hit record. I write skinflint pub.
It's sort of like looking at a geological
cross section of the neighborhood's
history, the bean post pub, the
Schnitzel House. On the left,
you can see how groups of people layered
themselves on top of groups of people
making themselves part of one of the
most deeply mixed neighborhoods in the
country. And when you get
just a little bit south,
it's impossible to not notice. One of
the latest groups trying to settle in
[inaudible] furniture almost got hit
by a car on the Yemen cafe, El Zahar.
Hello. Meet women walking
around and do job.
I've got a hookah lounge who
can nuts. That sounds nice.
Turkish Kebab as are. And how
large is the Arab community
in the 43rd district?
We don't have the exact, because again,
Father Leo team, when the sensors,
the Bartman kid 10 years ago,
they told the Arab community if
you are an Arab chick white, uh,
so we don't have specific numbers,
but the estimates I heard are
somewhere between 20 and 30,000. Wow.
Living in southwest Brooklyn,
that's a huge community. Yeah.
I mean that's only about 10% of
the total population. But uh,
in a Democratic primary for city council,
we need only about 4,000 votes
to one 4,000 votes total. Yeah,
that's it. That's it. Wow. Yeah.
I mean the turnout is very low and we
have an open seats so we'll have a bigger
chance winning because we're not
running against an incumbent. How,
what's the margin of victory typically?
Uh, they can be squeakers I mean a just,
uh, several years
back, uh, the race was
won by just 31 votes. Ah,
31. Yeah. So, so it would seem
that if this guy can just, well,
despite the fact that there's never
been an Arab American on city council
before, uh, it seems that if he can get
out the, uh, the Arab American vote,
he's got a shot shot. I mean, you just
told us there's a lot of Arabs there,
so he should, he should own this
election. Yes. But at the same time,
the neighborhood is such a microcosm.
I think that Islam is an evil
ideology. That's what I think of,
like everything that's going on. This
is Kayla. Kayla Santos, who also,
she's the former deputy director of the
Arab American Association of New York.
I am from, I'm what you
call it. And she said,
if you look around the neighborhood,
you'll see all these sort of national
level issues playing out on the ground.
It's like a, you know,
like a shadow play or something
and I fucking take the travel ban.
I mean you've got one of the
largest Muslim neighborhoods
in the country, right,
right next to all of these
people who voted for Trump,
who support the travel ban. No
immigration whatsoever, none,
zero and shifting national demographics.
We're one of the last remaining New York
City neighborhoods where there is still
a strong white working class
that is in the process of
being priced out. Gentrified.
[inaudible] is really hitting white people
hard and so clearly there's going to
be tension there like we've just got a
lot of the elements of the struggles and
the anxieties that are going
on on a national level. So
candidate log 1:10 AM
with all of this in mind,
we still are there in
search for new voters.
Their Elliot team ended up signing up
along with the help with his came pain
manager. He's full of dad
jokes. It's kind of amazing.
The woman you just heard a
couple of seconds ago. Kayla? No,
I'm the campaign manager for
Elliot Team for City Council.
Have you guys become like best
friends? She is my mother-in-law.
Why do you call me your mother-in-law?
Cause I love my mother in law set
out to represent the Arab community.
I am a candidate glowing with no
other candidates have gone before.
Captain Sea captain
encourage this captain Kirk,
captain huddles.
Was it the fruit? But Dad
joke aside, it's true.
He really is trying something that's never
been tried before and one reason that
it's never been tried before is that
those 20 some thousand Arab Americans for
the last 20 years they've been hiding.
Like for me just it's been unnerving to
to be in a district where you don't feel
like people are watching out for you in
your community. This is Linda Sarsour.
I have Palestinian Muslim American
community organizer born and raised in
Brooklyn,
New York and she says the key thing to
know is that not long after the nine 11
attacks, the u s government in 2003
did engage in a registration. Yeah.
She program
a registry called n Sears,
the national security entry
exit registration system,
which meant that males over the age of
16 who were from these like 29 countries
of origin countries that had a historic
connection to terrorism, Bangladesh,
Pakistan, Iran, Iraq,
Egypt. Go down the list.
People from those countries that
were visitors, temporary workers,
non US citizens had to come and formally
register with the federal government.
That really told me, give me people,
Muslim people treating us like animals.
That's it.
Linda was there with some of these men
providing translation services in this
post office like room where there are
all these windows the men would be called
upon at a time, photographed,
fingerprinted, look at their passport,
asked them general questions and I
noticed that at one point that there were
some men that were being told to either
leave or just go home and got some
stamps in their passport with future
appointments or they were telling them to
go to the 10th floor.
That's when my like something
like I got punched in the stomach,
like I felt really nauseous. I
was like, what's going on here?
So when I went to ask the officer,
she was told the 10th floor
was the FBI headquarters.
This wasn't just some
information gathering operation.
They were planning to deport people.
And as this realization sunk
in throughout the waiting room,
I can't tell you the faces
that these people had,
like they didn't know
what their destiny was.
And in fact about 10% of those that
did go register were put on deportation
proceedings and many of them were
deported. No going home, no packing a bag.
And I think that's
where the divide starts.
And so the Arab American population in
New York and a Bay Ridge learned it was
better to not show up, to not be
counted. And then just a few years later,
the Associated Press came out
with their investigative reports.
The Associated Press reports,
details how police used informants and
New York police department has operated
on intelligence unit targeting Muslims.
Turns out that after nine 11 the NYP was
putting large sections of the community
under varying degrees of
surveillance. This is not a Puzo.
I'm a reporter for the New York
Times based in Washington and he,
along with this team at the AP
back in 2011 broke this story.
We found out there was a unit
called the demographics unit,
secret team of NYP d intelligence
officer. These detectives,
they were mapping the human terrain of
New York snooping around neighborhoods
going into different shops, all the
Muslim, what's your shops? The cafes,
the bookstore's bars and nightclubs.
Restaurants could bars marking down
things like they play Al-Jazeera and it's
this far from a mosque. Informants
known as mosque crawlers.
Our mosques were under surveillance and
so the Arab community in Bayridge who
had done nothing wrong,
they were terrified.
I mean the police were even
keeping track of their kids,
like which parks do our kids
where, where we're playing soccer.
Couple of things worth
noting here, one, in the end,
the operation never turned
up any terrorists and to
when those things happen,
none of their local representatives,
no state legislator,
no local elected officials stood
up and said, this is wrong.
Don't target my constituents. You know,
these are these people are
from my district, nothing.
And what that does is it makes you feel
like the people quote in power don't
care about us. Like we
were out on our own.
And I started realizing that there was
going to have to be a moment where we had
somebody in, in the local
area, somebody who is Arab,
stand up and protect us. And this
is where Al Elio TeamSTEPPS in?
No, not quite yet.
So first Linda started to raise these
thoughts with the moms and business
leaders,
whole bunch of leaders from different
institutions and they decided that the
first step was to run a candidate,
um, for the New York City Council.
The idea was start small and start in a
place where they have a strong base bay
ridge, which also happened to be Linda's
neighborhood. And according to her,
a lot of the unions and a lot of the
people in the politics were like, Linda,
this is your seat. You
have to run for the seat.
So I saw it like unfold
before my very eyes.
But Donald J.
Trump is calling for a total and
complete shutdown of Muslims entering the
United States. The politics
changed. I think Islam hates us.
You know, nobody talks about we need
American Muslims on our front frontline.
Yes, we have to look at my
politically correct radical Islamism.
We have to see what's happening and
I'm joining me now as let as our floor
executive director of the Arab in this
new political climate I profile and grew
and as our sewer, Jesus, Linda Sarsour.
I started doing a lot of national work.
She was on all the cable news shows,
became a national figure and
really a polarizing one. What
why is that? Well, in large part because,
and I'm sure she would
hate me saying this,
but her brand oddly is very similar to
Donald Trump's. She can be very reactive.
She's just going to say it
like it is. I say straight.
I'm very Brooklyn and maybe too,
cause I was born and raised here,
but I tell it like it is. I don't really,
more than just telling it like it is,
she's a provocateur.
She's tweeted some tongue in cheek posts
about how sharia law wouldn't be that
bad. More recently she called
the CNN anchor, Jake Tapper,
a member of the outright. I mean,
she's Brash and feminist poster child
Linda Sarsour that this sour sour Linda
Sour tits are the
conservative media. Yeah,
I don't need counseling after
I hear Linda Sarsour speak,
I just need a bucket jumped all over for
it. There is the witch Linda sourcer.
She is a radical antisemites.
I did not submit to you taking these
missteps and warping them into totally
unfounded claims. Linda Sarsour, um,
she is an extremist who has
backed terrorists and that
the space won't be happy
until this whole goddamn country
is Muslim. Very conscious. Emily,
thank you for being Tracy.
So it just didn't feel right at the
moment and didn't want to run for the New
York City Council. And so after
four or five years of planning,
organizing and laying the groundwork
so that Linda Sarsour could run and
represent
the Arab community, there was
suddenly this moment of, Oh God,
what are we going to do?
You know this by the way again is
Kayla Santo Sue Oso who at the time was
working with Linda at the
Arab American Association.
And then I remember a moment when at the
association I walked in and I said to
her like, I just got out of a meeting
that Father Kay was in and I was like,
well, at that time I was like, I think
I was calling him reverend Elliot team.
I don't remember what we wrote when
I was calling him, but I was like,
don't you think he'd be a great
person to run for council?
And she like slammed her hand down
on the table and she's like, Kayla,
I was just thinking about the same
thing. It was like a light bulb went off.
So, uh,
we both like started going through our
heads of like why he meets us in the
middle, got all these connections with
people outside of the Arab community.
He's a parent, a public school students.
He worked at an Orthodox Jewish
hospital. He's the clergy,
the liaison to the NYP. Di Is Lutheran.
He's Arab, but he's Christian,
he's not Muslim.
And they started thinking like he's going
to be able to get votes that no other
Arab could
like, oh my God, he's like
the most intersectional.
Let me not use that jargony term.
He's like the person with the most
complex identity that might just be so
complex that it'll work.
And so the reached out to me on this
said, listen, we want you to do this.
And you know,
he thought about the fact that doing this
it would require him to quit his job.
It would be tough on his family,
but it felt again like here
was an opportunity to help
the people around it to
help the people in my
community. So, so I think,
I'm not sure if it's like the end of
the September where I became like,
yes, 100%
[inaudible]
and so I would bring my
Bush to Sydney Council.
A couple months later I announced on
February 26 this is not only my campaign,
this is yours. Lasage restaurant,
a local Lebanese restaurant. Yes.
Keith upfront shouting into the
microphone, blowing out the speakers.
Every single seat was filled. We
are going to win as we go into it.
And His message to them was essentially
we cannot sit and live in the shed
anymore. We have to be engaged.
We have to be involved.
We had to be part of the
decision making of this country.
We have to bring our perspective to the
table because the fact is other people
cannot represent us. So
let's not stick this to me.
We have to present ourselves.
I'm really getting lucky
with the book in the splits.
It's your relationship with
God. I don't think so. And
pretty much right off the bat,
those words like us and ourselves,
they presented a series of challenges
for father led team. Uh, the first one
being a large number of Arab
Americans who are American citizens,
but they are not registered and they
refuse to be part of the political system
in this country because
they don't trust it.
Like here is a community that has avoided
government to the nth degree for the
past decade and a half. So what does he
do? Well, during the month of Ramadan,
which is the holy month, and
three or four nights a week,
he would show up to the mosques with a
stack of literature and a larger stack of
voter registration forms.
They might if I leave my backpack
in the car here on the night.
I tagged along with him
and his campaign manager,
Kayla is mosque is actually
technically outside. It was hot,
muggy Elliott team was dressed
in his minister garb, you know,
suit and collar and I'm used to the boards
and as we walked into the mosque and
I take my shoes out here,
it wasn't at all clear to
me how this was going to go.
Considering what's happening
in the Middle East,
the ward and the division
and the different groups.
I was not sure if they were ready to
support the candidacy of an Arabic
Christian to represent them.
So we're standing in the back of this
huge room that has like green carpet and a
low low ceiling.
There are like 700 people there
standing shoulder to shoulder,
all praying in unison,
have to do this ritual four times.
And then there was a break in the prayer
are going to allow me to speak no to
address the peoples who didn't know that I
am here. So we sort of tiptoe
through all these people.
They're up at the front of
the moon, they introduce him
[inaudible]
and he launched into this space
just in the middle of prevented my
disability to New York [inaudible]
basically saying, you know,
this is our historic opportunity for the
Arab community to send their first ever
Arab American to city council.
And even with the language barrier,
you can hear the passion in this
speech and to respond to that was
tepid
at best. Yeah.
So when he was done,
we headed out to the front of the
mosque and as the service led out,
this sea of 700 people come
crashing out of the mosque
so that my liquor, you
haven't had good luck.
Their excitement for
him is on open display.
They're giving him hugs, they're
saying we're behind you. We love it.
I believe in this guy.
I think he is the best candidate in the
field and he will well represent the
community.
Only you can represent the
community. We are behind you. 100%
yeah, establish [inaudible]
and that evening, 1225 in the morning,
we are at mosque number two
we went to a second mosque.
[inaudible] need to go and then
a third. Are you doing good?
Get to see each time that same energetic
response, people are just pouring out.
He seems to know everyone and
most importantly, all of the pins
people were signing his petition to get
on the ballot. Okay. 39 Harden Avenue.
Okay, so just sign here and registering
to vote. It would just tell him please.
No, just throw him. So you
just registered to vote? Yes.
This is my first time registering many
of them for the first time. The best.
Did you just register on first time?
First Time only for him. You're
just a voter. You know what I mean?
Oh, what's up brother?
Ultimately everybody thinks we're insane
when we say we're investing a fair
amount of our resources and people who
have never voted before and people are
kind of like, what? You know, like
don't do that. It's a waste of money
because for many of these people,
the whole thing about registering
and then later voting,
it was a foreign language to them.
Sometimes when he'd ask
people to register to vote,
they'd respond back while we ordered the
give you money and there's 10 but this
is the process.
Other people thought that just registering
to vote was the same as voting for
him. I said, no, no, you're the black
vote for me. The potter, September 12.
But I signed the papers two weeks ago
and on top of that we did see signs of
that mistrust of government. I
have the register. You don't,
you want to get the first era
of American and city council
[inaudible] the first
time for a lot of people.
[inaudible] hiding under the radar.
But still, this is crazy. I didn't
think that we would get this much
after going from mosque to
mosque through all of Ramadan,
by like three months before the election,
we have registered close to 300
voters. So just at the mosques. Yeah.
And do you think, do you think you
can get those 4,000 votes from the,
from the Arab community alone?
We, we are, uh, you know, uh,
uh, not counting on the Arab.
We can think about 1000 votes
from the Arab community.
Wait, only a thousand votes.
Yeah, just a thousand.
Didn't you just say they were tens of
thousands of Arab Americans living there?
Well, yes, there are. There
are. So, but first of all,
if I get this correct,
about 250 Arab American votes were
cast in the last council primary 250
even getting to that 1000 number
was going to be a heavy lift.
And there's one more wrinkle
here. So I'm in Brooklyn.
We have about 800 families
that attend our church.
The folks you might expect to
be his most ardent supporters,
other Arab American
Christians. We main Orthodox
church in Egypt, like Sharif here,
Sharif, s. H. E. R. I. F. Um,
I am a deacon in the church. We're
gonna vote failure. I don't know. Yeah,
they were really interested
in supporting him.
Will you be voting for Father Heather
Elliott team? No. No, no, no. No.
You won't be. No. The beginning of my
campaign, I tried to reach out to them.
No. For me personally,
no. I feel pushback. No,
no. I don't know. Why is that
and what, what, what's going on?
Well, the Arabic Christians
in our districts are, uh,
the vast majority are
Republicans. Uh, so yeah,
I will say 95% of them are Republicans.
So that's number one. Number two,
you have the situation in Egypt
where Christians are being,
um, four now been killed after bombing
Christian churches in Egypt, uh,
of churches are being burned.
George's Church and Taunton
ripped apart these radical groups,
isis claiming responsibility.
Many of the dead are children.
Um, yeah, you, you see
there's tensions. Well,
and so is there a level of distrust
in the Christian Arab community of you
because you are so close with
the Muslim Arab community here?
I mean, I will give you an example.
I have very close, a friend of mine,
his name is Francois. And so
people went out to him and saying,
we cannot support him. And he
said, why not? Why? He said,
because he's very close with the Muslims
and they will take advantage of him.
So, but this is the dynamics,
this is what's happening.
So eventually they decided
only going after the Arab vote.
Wasn't the right numbers game, like
that's just not, it's just not gonna work.
And so what that meant was I need to
get 3000 votes from non Arabs in the
district to win this election.
In other words,
he was going to have to convince the
majority white voters that he could
represent them too, which wasn't
going to be easy. All right.
Walking down fifth year, as I discovered
when maybe a month before the election,
I went on a stroll to try to take the
pulse of some of the neighborhoods,
white residents. Have you lived here
in Bay Ridge for awhile? All my life.
Has the neighborhood changed
a lot? Yes. It's more,
it's more foreigners than American. Scary.
Listen to us
as 78 year old Irish woman.
You have newcomers
coming into our district.
What do they know about it? Nothing.
They do not know.
And when I asked them about Father
Lee team specifically, what did,
do you know anything about him?
No, I don't. And I don't care to,
honestly, I'd never heard of
them. The one that's running
right, he's Egyptian.
He's Palestinian. Okay.
Pouch still Egyptian. That's how I feel.
I just completely turns
me off. And just to be clear here,
you're a democrat. Yes. Yeah. Cool. Yeah.
Yeah. These are Democrats.
If anybody asks me to the vote for
Donald Trump or he was running,
I would turn around and Hell No.
But I feel this is our country.
This is America.
And I feel American person
should be in for office.
Was that representative of
what you heard? Was that, uh,
on that street on that day? Yes. Uh,
but clearly it's not like everyone down
there has these opinions and this by no
means excuses their behavior or language,
but I think it explains some of it that
they see rent prices going up and dozens
of new Arab folks moving into
the neighborhood every month.
But these are not the gentrifying
forest though. This is oddly enough,
the Arab immigrants and even
more so the Chinese immigrants,
they in some ways are, let's talk
about the issues that I hear and,
and every issue, jumping back to the
debate from the top of the piece,
this is one of the Republican candidates,
Liam McCabe, overcrowded schools,
whether it's infrastructure
and transportation,
it can be traced to one particular
issue in South Brooklyn.
And that isn't illegal home
conversion. Absolutely.
Developers or landlords are
taking these single family homes,
knocking out all the walls on the
ground floor in the second floor,
and then putting up these,
uh, these temporary walls,
building these very tiny cramped domiciles
that they can then rent out to 10 or
15 families. Oh. And what
that does is first of all,
it's incredibly unsafe for the
people living in the house,
but also it's putting stress on
the sewer system and streets. Uh,
it causes classroom sizes to go up. Uh,
housing prices go up because there are
just less actual single family homes on
the market. Uh,
it's making the neighborhood more
dense than it was ever meant to be.
And so for a lot of these people who have
lived in this neighborhood for a long
time, uh,
I think it feels like their daily lives
are being effected by these forces
outside their control and they are
reacting emotionally to those things.
So you're fighting for 'em I'm fighting
for the district fighting to make sure
the quality of life. Just one example,
there's a couple months
before the election lea team
was going around knocking
on doors. And what are your
views on illegal immigration? Uh,
we need to do the immigration reform.
We need to make sure the undocumented
are protected. Our sanctuary city. No,
no, you don't read my book.
It's not a sanctuary city. No,
I'm interested in to follow federal
law. I get my clock out of my sight.
Alright, thank you. Thank you.
You paid it all
in several of the Republican candidates.
You know, I deeply believe
that illegal immigration has,
it is a big group because of this.
We're trying to harness those emotions.
Come here legally. Get a
handout. Public health benefits.
That must stop it.
[inaudible]
one Republican candidate wrote about me.
I am a radical leftist Palestinian clerk.
Presumably they're using the word
cleric insinuating that you are not,
are not in fact Christian but you are
Muslim. Is that the insinuation there?
Yeah, I mean that is part of the plan.
They tried to use the feel of
the people against my candidacy.
Then the comments and the need
that post it is just terrifying.
I'm going to hang him. For
example, one guy said all this one,
I cannot read it on radio, but I
will show it to you. Read it. He,
he's a fucking asshole and
should be treated as such.
I have lived in this community for the
best 22 years and never in my life faced
anything like this.
And does really interesting because the
attacks not only coming from Republicans
but also coming from Democrats
in the race a but the Democrats,
they don't kind of under the table. Oh,
your team claims that some
of the Democrats are making
the argument that yes,
he might be able to win a democratic
primary. Uh, but because he's Arab,
he won't be able to win the general
election. So don't waste your vote on him.
And Justin Brandon, who's
really the establishment,
Democratic Front runner in the race,
his flyers and his lit says, oh,
what a neighborhood, our guy, uh,
so for me as an Arab American who are
living here, what that supposed to mean,
it is a [inaudible] a statement
of exclusion and that I,
I'll just say on that, uh,
as a white dude from Wisconsin,
when I see that flyer,
I don't see that division in
that. Am I just blind to it?
We,
you have to understand the context of
the neighborhoods and the context is
everything wrong in the neighborhood is
[inaudible] the Arab and the Chinese,
you know, if the streets is dirty
because of these dumb erupts, you know,
like when I go out and say I'm fighting
for the community and say Hasi is just
only fighting for his community,
it means only the Arab people.
But if somebody else said the word
community, it's okay. It means everybody.
And I don't mean to push
back, but it seems like, okay.
It seems like you two are essentially
doing the same thing to one another. Yeah.
He's saying, when you
say the word community,
it's only about the Arab community.
And when he says our neighborhood,
you're saying he's just talking
about the white folks in Bay Ridge.
Isn't it the same thing
happening in both directions?
It could be a, but we need to
understand the backgrounds.
We have a president who
use so much rhetoric.
He came up with the Muslim
ban and building the wall and,
and attacking minorities
and people of color. Uh,
our councilman and his staff never took
a stand on these issues and came out in
support of the Arab and
Muslim community. That's,
you have to look at the history and, well,
it seems like maybe his opponents are
playing up this kind of identity politics
over and over again. I saw
Elliott making explicit
attempts to reach out across
those boundaries. I like this.
And Republicans take this, for example,
at this noisy firefighter bar,
he strolled up to this table of burly
white men and just started giving hoax.
And I mean, just listen to
how Brooklyn he sounds here.
Let's do that once more. Are you filming?
Is he behaving like you'd
be like, yes please.
The whole thing has been
a really delicate line.
Kayla Santos who so because we
really want it to be honest and,
and not adjust too much. Um,
but while also like letting people know
that this campaign wasn't just for the
Arab community, it was for them as well,
nine,
nine to 59 and so the campaign
was also focusing on things that,
well, things that mattered to
everyone. What's happening here,
they're doing a complete
renovation of the station.
There's no r train at the station,
you know, a real daily life concerns.
The physician is going to be closed
for at least five months. As you see,
it's chaotic.
On a cloudy morning lea team set up a
podium right in front of the cordoned off
staircase of a closed subway station and
railed against the MTA for doing with
next to no warning at all these repairs
that were really just cosmetics weren't
needed at all. We think
about our students,
we think about our small business
owners a months about shoves,
who will be affected, impacted for the
closing this station for no reason.
I mean,
what's more unifying here in New York
then complaining about the subway to
improve the city. And he also
went after specific groups,
groups who were traditionally white.
I just want to say thank you so much
for this opportunity to invite me to be
with you tonight. Uh,
like on this rainy Thursday night in this
wide WCA multipurpose room that felt a
lot like an elementary school cafeteria.
And I thank you for inviting me to share
my reasoning why I'm running for city
council.
And also to tell you that I will be very
proud to be the first one to represent
the democratic socialist in City Hall,
who, who are the Democratic Socialists?
These are the Bernie Sanders people.
And the important factor now is there
are lots of anti-establishment white
people in this district.
This neighborhood in the presidential
primary went Bernie and went Trump.
He beat Hillary. He beat Hillary
in this district. So, oh,
your team has to put
on the clothes of yes.
A Brooklyn Jew and
watching him try to do that
couple of things struck me. It said
that was born and raised in Bethlehem,
Palestine. Uh, and my father
actually also carpenter,
no, no relation.
Not In this first how he was intentionally
bringing parts of himself to the for
uh, well pushing other
parts into the background.
So I'm going to tell you that uh,
we have some commonalities together and
second we are committed to justice and I
think that's why you are
here tonight, right? Yeah.
Otherwise you all in the wrong room.
No.
How we highlighted specific policies
that represented those parts of himself.
Issues like economic justice. If
free education, our universities,
I have two daughters in college
and I know how much it cost me.
I know that my wife and I,
we have to get a second job to be
able to pay for them to go to college.
So they decide to support them or no?
Well in fact they did.
He was endorsed by the
Democratic Socialists of America,
both the local and national chapters of
the organization, which was a huge deal.
Yes. 100%. And that was like,
hey, we are a business now.
It's now it's interesting, right?
Because with that endorsement
came some real support.
I came to the campaign through the DSA.
DSA seemed like a good conduit locally.
They committed hundreds of volunteers.
We had 150 200 volunteers yesterday.
The sort of manpower that allowed
them to flood the neighborhood
and knock on thousands of bottles.
Michael, I mean need to about
trying to convince people to vote.
Flint people understood the
stances on the legislation.
Really excited about
that. I'm feeling good,
Dara,
and more than just helping them knock
on doors because of the national
endorsement on many evenings of the week,
they actually had folks from all over
the United States phone banking for him,
calling from places like Florida
to Bay Ridge, Brooklyn. Again,
pitching people to vote
for father your team.
I'm trying to show that my
candidacy for city council.
It is for everyone in this
district and this is this.
I find this so fascinating about you
that I see such a contradiction in
everything you're saying there that
you're saying you want to represent the
whole community, which I'm sure
you do, but at the heart of it,
like what's motivating that is wanting
to give voice to this group of people
that don't have a voice. Absolutely. I
mean that is 100% and I cannot deny that.
I mean one of the most motivating factors
me running because I wanted to make
sure my community has a
voice and has representation,
but I'm running to the
present everyone, you know,
I mean at this weird,
because you know, uh,
was that a question in
your mind going into this,
like how do I walk this
in incredibly tiny,
tight rope of telling the Arab community,
I am you and this is our moment,
but simultaneously telling the
majority of the neighborhood like,
but I'm still you too. Like
don't worry. I can be both.
People have to understand my identity.
I mean I went and knocked
on thousands doors.
We talked to people and my,
my talking points of the door
was always, I'm a father of four.
My wife is a school nurse. Um, uh,
I love this community. And then the,
I didn't speak on the, about
the Arab and Muslim community.
I spoke about affordability,
livability in the community.
We spoke about transportation, we
spoke about, uh, police accountability.
We spoke about things that people in the
community said in this district said,
yes, we are going to support you.
We need somebody like you
who can go and our behalf.
So at the end of the day,
uh, my identity is who I am.
I am running as who I am and I will not
allow anybody to take that away from me.
And so just a couple of days before
September 12th, uh, before the election,
I checked in with Kayla to
see how things were looking.
How many days do we have
left here? Five days.
Okay.
Yeah. And apparently she told me, uh,
as l u team and his canvassers had
been going around to all of these doors
knocking. They had been taking
notes on people. And in those notes,
each person was given a
number from one to five
based on their level of support.
One is like that person
was so pro Elliot team,
you didn't even need to go to that
door. You're just marking them down.
Five is like, sorry, I'm
voting for somebody else.
Twos and ones are positive ids
and just a couple of days before the
election, an election, I'll remind you,
they only need 4,000 votes to win.
The number of positive
ids they had was 5,500
so you currently have 5,500 give
or take. Yeah, ones and twos.
Yeah,
so will be very interesting to see how
the prime minister will be translated in
numbers when the September 12 comes.
Okay,
well we're going to take a break and
when we come back it'll be election day.
Election Day.
This is Jeffrey and this is
Marjorie from Boise, Idaho.
Radiolab is supported in part by
the offered piece, Sloan Foundation,
enhancing public understanding of science
and technology in the modern world.
More information
aboutSloan@wwwdotsloan.org
in Los Angeles.
You know about the $4,000 a month
apartment to hundred dollars pet grooming
sessions and the $7 lattes.
But what really causes gentrification
and who wins and loses as a neighborhood
changes. I'm soul Gonzales, host of,
there goes the neighborhood la
from KCRW and w NYC studios.
It's a new podcast series
about a change in Los Angeles.
Listen and subscribe to their goes to
neighborhood where ever you get your
podcasts.
Jad Roberts, Radiolab, and we're
going to go back to Simon Adler.
Should we do election day? Yeah,
yeah. Let's have an election. Okay.
What happens? So the election, uh,
this is September 12th. All right,
so it is six
in the morning when he
17 son is yet to rise.
We are outside the a l e a team
a get out the vote headquarters.
Here we go.
Where's the lift that we're
using for that, ma'am?
And so I show up at six in the morning
and everything is already a buzz already
over there. It's crazy. There were
dozens of volunteers, staff workers.
You're all so amazing. Thank
you for coming this morning.
I'll bring around these plastic folding
tables that were set up everywhere.
Don't leave without one or two signs.
So what we're going to do is we're
going to give you a giant stack of
literature. Says, all right, sweet. And
shortly, shortly after I got there, uh,
Kayla [inaudible], Father
Elliott team both arrived
[inaudible]
we're matching. That's pretty awesome.
No, it's got the memo. Yeah, right.
They were in a matching Democrat,
blue Kayla in blue jeans and a
blazer father Elliott team, uh,
in an Oxford with the,
the white collar and blue through
saying today's election that wow,
this is a September 12th and
as quickly as he arrived. Yeah,
no, uh, no opposition, insight and uh,
enjoy yourself was sent out
to start that. Oh yeah. 86th,
beautiful day in the neighborhood.
And so a sub beautiful
day in the neighborhood.
We hopped in his car and that was
sort of the beginning of the day.
And really his job was just to shake as
many hands of as many people as he could
in as many different disparate
parts of the district as possible.
Are you boarding today? The hot
southeast you speak Arabic or English,
what should be
be the basis of whether
or not you win a race,
his Id and pull id as many
positive ideas as you can.
Pull out as many of those
people on election day pull out,
meaning pull them to the polls. Exactly.
Get as many of your positive ideas out
to the polls as you can and for their
campaign to do this, we have to
effectively have two different operations.
First and foremost.
I know, sorry [inaudible].
There's gotta be an Arab community
operation. You've worked,
so we have likely Arabic speakers.
Their assumption was that an Arab voter
is going to need their handheld much
more tightly to get them to the polls.
It's like a lot of these people have
never been to the polls before and so,
okay, can you just give her a message?
Then they had like six people on their
phones just going down these lists.
I'm calling to speak to
[inaudible] calling people saying,
have you come out and voted today?
The family, thank you so much.
Simultaneously, that same
person who has been called,
I'm basically the person that actually
make sure that you go boat is being
flanked by a group of canvassers.
All right? This is a Mohammad
marching up to their apartment
and banging on their door saying
one C, two e BD,
four a and 40 come out and vote.
We're gonna pull you out to you eyes.
Know what
time we're going to say like,
what time are you going to the polls
up from the wartime nine or, yeah,
nine [inaudible]. We need you to
go, go father k needs you to go.
I met him.
They had this very, uh,
long script they would go through and
I don't remember all of the Arabic,
but they would often say, so are
you going to the polls today?
And the response would be,
and Shalla like God willing.
And they weren't supposed to accept
that. They'd have to say, no, no, no, no,
no, no, no, no, and Charlotte tomorrow,
today, not God willing. You Willing?
And then they would have to get them to
say either like I promised on my head or
I promise on my heart. And
if they got either of those,
then they felt like they had imposed
social pressures that would work on the
Arab community. Yeah,
and then on top of all this,
we have to do the standard operation of
get out the vote with the triple prime
voters,
which is like the voters that have
that reliably vote in primaries in this
community. Largely white, largely
over the age of 50 all right.
Saint Nicholas old folks home, he voted.
I am back again going into nursing homes,
sending out even more canvassers and even
the occasional shout out the passenger
window of your car and early on in the
day back at the campaign headquarters.
All right. If I need to
read that [inaudible] yeah,
I need somebody who's a free now when he
needs it to go become a quote from him.
It was clear just how complicated and
resource intensive running these two
parallel campaigns was. Just a
couple of people at to vote a,
I'm going to say the that'll your team
had just received a call from several
Muslim women saying that they needed
a ride to the polls. His wife,
grace was going to go pick them
up, but she needed someone to,
I mean the, and you know I'm going
to go with them to get the voters.
So this organizer said she would
do it, but she, no, no, no.
You can leave the table.
You guys do. Yeah,
I'll deal with it.
Pain directors, Andy, it
said no, you've got to stay.
Don't text whatsapp. WHATSAPP. I
live with a girl. Take this one.
I'll take care of this. Can
pick up a voter. Yes. Mohamed,
can it be Mohammed like just
send Mohammad [inaudible]
it turns out, uh, Mohammed doesn't speak.
Somebody speaks Arabic, which no,
look necessarily eventually turned
out to not actually be a problem.
So why doesn't Mohammad please
those I know. I know. I know.
So why does it mamas, they can too much
come here. So go.
But then we dad pointed out
earlier that if these are women,
it would be more appropriate for all
those going to pick them up to be women.
Um, [inaudible] you know,
cultural stuff that say what can be here.
I can take my place for a little
bit. I'll think your president.
So finally busy day, hectic.
They said we. Dot. Just go. Yeah, exactly.
And this was all for just two votes,
but I will say despite all
that, midway through the day,
it did appear like this two
pronged approach was working.
This is his first time voting. I
voted yes. Good. Yeah,
I did. Yeah, you did
those 50 doors. 50 doors. Yeah. 71 people,
canvassers. We're getting good feedback.
And on the street that that Adam anthem,
both first time voters will
have just told him Arab folks
and hello, I bought it
for your white folks.
We're coming up to him and saying
like what happened about hey,
we voted for you.
[inaudible] this is rob yet the canvasser
who's been with the campaign from the
beginning. You don't understand what this
means for the Abbey medical community.
You only know what it means.
So it's pretty personal.
Have you voted today right?
I'm going to get all the money.
You're getting emotional. I
don't want to be emotional.
My husband is banned in Malaysia
because he swim yet, man.
Okay, Ken, do this
cause I'm chilling. Yes.
Yeah, that's good. Have
you voted. Thank you.
So yeah, it is very personal.
Okay.
But then, hi,
how are you in Elliott team's car
at about two in the afternoon.
How's the numbers looking?
They got their first sense of what
voter turnout was looking like.
Yeah,
right, right. Yeah.
So the numbers side of that
were underperforming in a
few poles sites where we
should be doing better.
And you know, uh, sorry,
let me start that again.
I'm like frazzle now. Um,
this is Mohammad con the campaigns
treasurer. Yeah. The number said that,
you know,
poll sites where we have strong support
are showing lower turnout than we are
hoping for. Um, so obviously we
don't know who people are voting for,
but we're guessing that since the
last people are voting their overall,
that means that less
folks are voting for us.
And then pull sites where we know our
opponent has strong support and we're
seeing higher turnout.
And so w what are the
strategies to remedy that?
So we just need to allocate more
canvassing resources to areas where we see
underperformance so we can
turn more people out to vote.
So go knock on those doors
hard, knock on the doors,
pull people out of their
homes and make sure they vote.
And so with about four
hours remaining. Yep.
So right now it's all about
talking to individuals,
dragging people off the streets.
All of the leaders of the campaign,
including Linda Sarsour. You literally
got to find people that are recognizable.
If hit the streets, I'd go to shops.
I got Steve at the move
of North Bay Ridge.
They were literally going into
Arab owned stories, telling them,
you gotta go to the polls and you
did not. I'm taking you right now.
Barbershops, Delis, hookah,
lounges. Yeah, he's going go vote.
This symptom is $80 fee to vote.
[inaudible] changing his clothes.
You're going to vote. See,
they could have two votes.
And while this was happening,
I don't live in a district.
I'm here to help out my way.
I'm here to canvas for the final
push of volunteers. We're showing up.
It's a good time to push again.
Yeah. Do we go a fourth pass?
Yes. Go, go, go, go. Let's go. Let's
go. Let's go. Let's go. Let's go.
Come on.
And when they got the updated
turnout numbers. Yeah.
Yeah.
We have two of our poll sites that have
been hit at 115% of turnout already seem
to be working. So we just got
to keep that up. What's the,
what's the emotion at the
moment? Yeah. I don't know.
I mean it's a close race there. I like it.
At least it feels like it based on the
turnout numbers that we're seeing in the
way that turnout is happening.
There's basically two strongholds that
are currently developing North Bay Ridge,
South Bay Ridge.
Oh, a South Bay Ridge,
which is largely white,
seems to be turning out hard for the
establishment candidate, Justin Brannan.
Uh, and North Bay Ridge is where, uh,
the majority of the Arab Americans live.
And in that moment, uh,
the campaign makes it,
um, so at this point we're zeroing in
all of our efforts on just, you know,
everything north of 75th street,
that the only way to win is to push
hard to get as many votes as they can in
those Arab American neighborhoods and
essentially right off trying to convince
the white voters. So this is
like, you know, we got it.
It's our people are going to make the
difference. It'll be good for our people.
Yes.
We're doing good. We've got to
stay in our town. Yeah, that's it.
And the focus on our part of town. And so
would like an hour
remaining. Everyone went out.
Let's do this for one final point.
Sure. [inaudible]
I see
when I come back,
cars were driving by honking their
horns for him in southwest Brooklyn.
Really believe this
just wrote the 12 hour shifts.
[inaudible] thank you so much.
Thank you so much my man.
Thank you so much brother.
Thank you. I'll be in my
living room as I'm going.
I'm going to all the best companies. Can
you take a picture of us? Sure. Yeah.
[inaudible]
uh, by my watch, it is a nine o'clock.
[inaudible] the campaign is over.
[inaudible] shall love. I didn't,
I was with lea team right when we
hit nine o'clock. And in that moment,
I don't know from where, but someone
handed him what's up baby. Okay.
An infant. And he was just
standing on this dark street, uh,
his back against a minivan,
his face illuminated by the light pouring
out from his campaign headquarters
with this baby in one arm and his cell
phone press tightly up against his ear
asking Kayla,
I don't know what the
numbers were looking like.
We're still counting.
All of his volunteers,
staff and supporters were gathering in
the patio of this bar pizzeria called the
firefly that over to the soul waiting
there for Elliot team to arrive as well as
the results.
Kayla called me as I was woken up to the
firefly pizzeria because at that time,
the numbers from South
Brooklyn came in. She said,
I've added these results with what we
already know. And uh, she said, uh,
we lost.
Mm.
The moment before I
walked into [inaudible]
badly, let's see about
the fight or flight.
[inaudible]
after word got around that they
had in fact lost on Linda Sarsour.
So, um, stood up on this picnic
table and addressed everyone.
I know a lot of folks who are here
who are not children of immigrants,
or if you're not Arab American or Muslim,
you do not understand what this campaign
meant to us and to our communities.
And for us it is not over. And
I want to say to father, father,
father color did not have to do this.
He did not have to quit his job,
a father of four. But
Father Heather did it.
He did it to help us build the political
voice that we knew we always had in
this community to allow people to
pay attention to us and our issue.
Guys, we're doing this
again without any backup.
[inaudible]
wait, so we lost do we to, do
we know, do they know why? Yes.
So ended up losing by
a just under 700 votes,
which is about 7% of the total votes
cast, which we know what, what, uh, what,
what accounted for the
difference? Yeah. We, we can't
know for sure why, uh,
because the voter records
don't come out until December.
But there are a couple of things
that we do know. One was that, uh,
there were no Arabic translators
at the polls. Really? Yeah.
You see how far I can get?
I'm just following. We
actually had reporters, Syrah,
Karrie go down into one of the polling
locations to see exactly what was going
on.
Hi.
Can I just ask what languages you guys
are translating Cantonese and Mandarin?
I bet you kintone Spanish.
English to Spanish. Okay.
Is there somebody a, an Arabic translator?
Fortunately Arabic is not a approved
language for him to have an interpreter in
Brooklyn will actually in New
York. I believe it's sustainable.
Turns out what languages are provided
in any borough of New York City.
A are decided upon based on census data
and because there is no census data.
Oh, come on in Arab community.
So angry. Yeah. That's why.
Did they say you can't come here? Like
are they or do they just go neutral?
Well, the, the problem was, uh,
the interpreters that the campaign was
attempting to provide for these folks at
several of the polling locations, they
were actually turned away from the polls.
I told you by the New York state
officials, by the election, people,
by the folks working the
polls were really, which I,
which it turns out is illegal.
They were illegally turned away.
They were illegally turned
away. But, um, despite all that,
they did in fact get out
more Arab American voters
than have ever turned out for
a race like this, like by a
factor of four by oh four.
That's interesting. Where they ended up,
uh, coming up short, it would seem, uh,
is with the white voters and uh, nobody
has a perfect explanation for this,
but I,
I did talk to some political movers and
shakers down in the area and they, uh,
they offered up sort of three different
explanations. Um, one is that, uh,
the message that he was delivering to
the white folks just failed to connect.
The second one is that, uh, having
these two campaigns at the same time,
one for the Arabs, one
for the white folks,
that that just damned
him from the beginning.
Just like in terms of resources
or in terms of messaging,
all of the either a and then
the third one is that, uh,
this had nothing to do with him. This
had nothing to do with this campaign.
Just in this moment there were not enough
white folks who would be willing to
vote for an Arab candidate.
Uh, no matter what.
No, no. It's nice to hear,
to be able to speak back to it.
We're emotionally, where are
you? Are you like, all right.
Have you or you like gotten past
a couple of weeks after the election? Um,
I headed back down to Bay Ridge to sit
down one more time with father lea team.
Well, the truth is that I
haven't taken a day off yet. Why?
Because I've been so busy. Why
are you doing this to yourself?
Not doing this to myself. It is just a, a,
the outcome of this campaign
has been unbelievable. So
the moment we finished with the campaign,
we continued to meet to discuss the
political power that we have built,
whether we are going to do with it,
because we have almost 3000
people came out and voted.
We can make a difference in any election.
And that's why I said we
cannot slow down. Now.
We need to continue to
educate the community.
We need to continue to be engaged with
them. We cannot lose the momentum.
We cannot afford to lose the
momentum. We just can't. So this is,
are you a politician
now? Like in that way,
this is the will of the
community. We have demands,
we have political power and um,
we have an address now and the
address is Heather Elliott team. Uh,
so elected officials,
we will not talk to us.
You come and speak to us
through Heather Elliott team.
That's the only way you can talk to us.
[inaudible]
wow. Yeah. I feel like what
struck me in that conversation,
uh,
with like he spent his entire campaign
trying to speak to all sorts of different
groups. He was saying, I can represent
you all. I am yours. Everyone,
but in that final conversation, uh,
what I heard from him in that it was a
can becoming more and more a voice of
just one group, one
community, his community.
Mm. Well that's, yeah, but I sat
co, you know, this is the game.
I feel like this is him recognizing the
nature of the game and deciding to come
from a position of strength.
And I say awful. I'm also,
you want him to basically tightened his
grip on the Arrow vote and then walk
into room after room. Of
course, New York City, you say,
when you want to our votes deal
with me. I've got votes to push.
I've got votes to given with hold
of my boss. I tell you what I want.
I want that community to step out and be
heard and have a voice and this is how
it happens. I think it has to,
if you believe in this system,
it has to be possible for someone talented
enough to be able to stand up and say
two things at the same time.
Two things that seem contradictory that
he does believe in and that has to be
possible. Yeah, I understand that.
But I mean in this particular moment,
in this particular, I mean,
I don't think identity politics is a
choice in this moment. You know? I mean,
you remember the woman who was like
still Egyptian, still Egyptian.
He's being seen as one
thing that he is not,
that that doesn't mean
choosing what do you do?
You can't just like pretend to have a
rainbow coalition when there's no chance
of that or you can fight.
Ah, you got that out of your system.
Yes. Sorry, just you were saying
through your piece here. I'm sorry. Yes.
So how does he feel?
Yeah, I was going to
say, oddly enough, uh,
I tried to put all of this
in front of him. Well,
that uh, that brings me actually to the
question that I think is at the heart of
everything I've watched is you were
really trying transcend identity politics.
You were trying to at one time speak to
those people and yet at the same time
say no, that my Arab ness has nothing
to do with this. You tried to do both.
And I think
that,
I worry that that is why it didn't, yeah.
Work.
Mm. I don't know.
Yeah.
Uh, I have to think about
what you just said, but, uh,
uh, you know, I went out there as myself
as an Arab American Lutheran Pastor,
but I had to take stands on issues that
really mattered to me and to the things
that I am passionate about.
What does that mean? You're sort of a
better person than you are a politician?
I like to see myself like that.
Definitely. I mean, I did,
I did what I thought, what my team
thought was the right thing to do.
And, uh,
would you, would you run again?
Uh, sure. Yes.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
our story was reported and produced by
Simon Adler with production help from
Bethel hobday and Annie
Mcewen. Real quick,
some special thanks to
[inaudible] and Polica.
Tina's David Lewis and Bridget
Burgen from the w NYC newsroom. Uh,
Ralph Perfetto and Justin
Brannan, Rebecca chasten,
David Fox Sakari and Annie McCoon
for their help gathering tape. Uh,
the Muslim Democrats of New York,
Salam, Arabic Lutheran church,
and everyone on the Heather Lee
team for city council team, uh,
for putting up with me for eight
months now. Obviously thanks to Simon.
You're welcome. All right, well, ready?
Get out of here. I'm ready to go.
All right.
Hi there. My name is Michelle [inaudible]
and I'm calling from Kansas City,
Missouri. And I'm going
to read the credits.
I apologize in advance if I
mispronounce any of the names.
Radiolab was created by Jack FM Rod
and is produced by Soren Wheeler.
Dylan Keefe is our director of sound
design. Our staff includes Simon Adler,
Rachel Cusick, David Gebel, Bethel
Hottie Tracy Hunt, Matt Kielty, Robert,
Annie Mcewen, Latif, Nasser,
Melissa Donald, Arianna Wack,
and Molly Webster with help from
Amanda around chick. She, Molly,
David Fox, and Gar fatale,
Phoebe Wang and Katie Ferguson.
Our fact checker is Michelle Harris.